du gehört 17 RX strong im Mund und
stinkt immer noch eine Müllhalde
das hört sich echt nicht gesund an
die habe ich vergessen abzuholen die
wurde zurückgeschickt
es wird genauso zurückgeschickt wie
meine Kamera
ich mache gerade ein Kartentrick machen
ich zeige euch jetzt Kartentrick
[Applaus]
du hast gar keinen Karten das hier habe
ich ja noch nie verstanden ne 8 bis 99
was machen dann hundertjährige die
dürfen
das war es nicht das war die Tür
[Musik]
ig
also ja es ist cool dass hier stoppt
Mobbing auf dem Spiel drauf steht und
ich glaube jeder ist gegen Mobbing aber
keiner
Gesundheit keine Person die wirklich
jemanden mobbt fertig macht beleidigt
wird sich doch dann denken nee den
beleidige ich jetzt nicht weil auf
diesem Spiel stand drauf stoppt Mobbing
das ist genauso wie diese Bilder an so
Autobahn wo sie steht Handy weg das
hängt ja noch genauso ab dieses Schild
damals ich habe euch übrigens auch gar
nicht gesagt wo ich hier bin ist aber
glaube ich irgendwie auch logisch ich
glaube ich habe in Köln auch schon was
aufgenommen
hey Mama Preis für die dümmste Steckdose
der Welt geht auf jeden Fall an dich
das Messer hier oben sieht einfach aus
dieser Monster haben lecker Gurke
schreibt mal bitte unten in die
Kommentare wie Wassermelonen wachsen
nein du bist jetzt nicht die Leute
sollen das sagen
[Musik]
deine Mutter
ey auf jeder einzelnen Karte steht Stopp
Mobbing drauf hätten sie Ernährung in
einer Schublade Schokolade und Salate
das eine Nutella noch komplett voll aber
schon eins auch sehr und noch mehr Honig
das sieht auch schon Honig
[Musik]
so ich war jetzt für 10 Minuten draußen
für die nächsten zwei Jahre wir wollten
über Basketball spielen gehen
wird nur leider nichts wir haben neue
Spiele entdeckt und davon gerade sechs
Runden gespielt ich habe einfach alle
gewonnen hätten es einfach schlecht zu
verlieren der Welt und weil ich so gut
war mein dass ich als Belohnung jetzt
McDonald's Essen trinke
ich hätte gerne ich hätte gern zwei
McFlurry ja ohne Soße
ohne Bacon bestellt
kennt ihr das wenn ihr so im
formuliere ich das jetzt simpel und
prägnant kurz für einen Clip kennt ihr
das wenn ihr euch im Spiegel anguckt
oder euch so denkt boah ja wenn ihr im
Spiegel guckt und wenn ihr dann Foto
macht dann man ich will einfach sagen
dass irgendwie sieht man im Spiegel
immer deutlich besser aus als wie man
auf Fotos aussieht
gesagt 20:15 Uhr ist einfach so eine
Zeit die Deutschland repräsentiert es
ist 20:15 Uhr jetzt geht auf jedem
Sender irgendein Film los
disco Pogo kommt ihr eure Wassermelone
auch immer ein Bolognese bevor die erste
Tag ist zwar jetzt vorbei da wir
allerdings irgendwie nicht so richtig
erlebt haben Block ich morgen auch noch
seit 40 Stunden ihre Haare das ist
einfach immer diese Angst Moment wenn
das da hoch geht
oh gott macht man Screenshot von mir und
schickte mir auf insta dann habe ich
vielleicht bald mal ein neues cooles
Bild was ich hochladen kann
das ist übrigens die schlechteste
Autofahrerin Europas das stimmt wir
dachten eine Zeit lang das ist Stella
werbe es ist wirklich leider Peyton nein
Vorwärtsgang
hässlich und billig Qualität hat
übrigens früher an der Grundschule meine
Basketball Verein gespielt und meinte
sie wird jedes Mal den Kopf treffen
[Musik]
ist einfach New York auf wish bestellt
der größte und den ich je gesehen habe
das aber ein alter Opa da verstehst also
wir waren was essen
hatte Termine
du warst dabei ich war eigentlich das
heute den ganzen Tag eigentlich nur so
daneben
ja keine Ahnung ich wollte euch das gar
keinen Sinn ergeben hat dass ich jetzt
gesagt habe dass ich den heutigen Tag
auch noch Glaube war ich einfach
überhaupt nichts ne das Brot ich finde
das hier so ekelhaft ne echt einfach so
Fleisch Sticks nur zur Info ich bin
mittlerweile in Köln angekommen mache
jetzt hier so einen kleinen Trödelmarkt
weil ich halt bald aus meiner Wohnung
hier erstmal ausziehe für 3 Monate weil
dann alles umgebaut wird und deswegen
kommen gleich ein paar Freunde vorbei
die nicht ein paar Sachen schenken will
ja das mittlerweile angekommen so
kurz beim Duschen sehen hier komm mal
kurz rein
[Musik]
duschen ist aber wir lassen einfach nur
Wasser laufen damit ein bisschen Wasser
in die Leitung kommt
Wasser Verschwendung aber es muss sein
er muss
[Musik]
ich arbeite gerade der Flohmarkt läuft
meine lieben Freunde
alles irgendwie aussortiere ich habe
gesagt ich verschenke aber meine Freunde
und hat sie direkt die die wunderschönen
Bilder gesichert die sind von Pablo
Picasso damals ja auch fotografiert
worden
ist das grundlegendes die würde ich mir
dann also ich guck mal vielleicht um
mich herum ins Musik
danke
Schuhe kommst du da nicht rein in die
Schuhe kommst du da nicht rein so wie
Typen die nicht schwanger werden wollen
also
er würde halt
nochmal machen die schwarzen haben halt
190 € gekostet ich hatte die kein
einziges mal an so scheiße sehen jetzt
nicht aus finde ich ich will einfach
nicht wegschmeißen oder so ernst das ist
der kleinste hier im Raum das ist die
größten Schuhe die gar nicht mal so
scheiße
verstanden als Vierer die schwarze
weißt du was halt zu den Schuhen noch
richtig gut passen würde
komm schon sehr gefährlich könnt ihr
euch mal alle im Kreis drehen
ich wollte einfach nur eine Runde
Flaschen drehen spielen
von dir kommen können
ich habe eine frage
kannst du mir sagen wer das ist
okay und wer ist denn das
keine Ahnung
Cutter servus ich mache das richtig gut
kannst mich einstellen perfekt
an der Stelle will ich den heutigen
Block jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben Freunde schreibt immer in
die Kommentare wie ihr meine neue Kamera
findet
zu Beginn des Vlogs habt ihr ja gesehen
dass bei meiner alten Kamera der Zoom
kaputt gegangen ist und jetzt habe ich
meine neue Kamera abgeholt ist der das
besser jetzt schreibt in die
[Musik]